I've noticed you're pretending to
masturbate and I was wondering if you
wanted to talk about it
my mom was a sex guru so why don't you
start by telling me your earliest memory
of your scrotum
can't hear my sexually repressed friend
our chance to finally move up the social
food chain
I'm worried about you man everybody's
ever thinking about shagging about to
Shag or actually Shag in
the students at the school need your
help and we need their money I'll deal
with the business and things and you can
do therapy therapy yes Sex Therapy like
your mum wow sex therapists this could
be awesome it could be popular
I might have a mild to moderate crush on
me
I'm addicted to wanking my pubes are out
of control I wish I could be a normal
kid with a normal dad with a normal dick
I have for the best two years of Our
Lives
[Music]
thanks Mom
[Music]
stay out of my life
what kind of man do you want to be what
kind of mad you want me to be dead
you can't choose who you're attracted to
you can't engineer a relationship I
don't believe in love you are who you
are
don't let anyone take that away from you
[Music]
[Music]